a source tells et that paris hilton is
not offended by the comments britney
spears made about her
during last week's court testimony for
her ongoing conservatorship battle
britney spears is the most beautiful
girl in the world and i love her music
more than anyone quote paris and
brittany have known each other and been
friends for years
paris knows britney's comments were
taken out of context
and not meant to be an attack against
her or what she's been through by any
means
the source adds that the dj fully
supports brittany
and knows that britney has her back too
they've shared so many memories together
over the years and paris is confident in
their relationship
thank you so much sweetie while speaking
to the judge last week
britney referenced paris claims in her
2020 documentary this is paris
where the 40-year-old heiress alleged
that she was verbally and physically
abused at a boarding school when she was
17 years old
paris made the claims in august alleging
that her time at the boarding school was
quote torture
and in brittany's testimony she
referenced paris's allegations as a
reason why she never spoke openly
against her conservatorship
saying she initially didn't believe
paris claims and felt in turn
that nobody would believe her either you
should know we believe her
yeah following the pop star's testimony
on wednesday
paris sister and mom nikki and kathy
hilton were guests on andy cohen's late
night talk show watch what happens live
and said they support brittany 100
percent
free britney such a sweet girl
and a good girl while paris who's been
friends with the baby one more time
singer for over a decade
has shown her support for the superstar
many times
back in august she told the sunday times
quote it breaks my heart that people
have so much control over her
it's not fair to be an adult and be
treated like a child
i can't imagine having to live my life
like that
and more recently in may paris praised
brittany while chatting with e.t
i love her i was actually texting with
her last week and she's just
so sweet and down to earth and really an
amazing woman
and i'm just so proud of her and
following the pop icons testimony
paris sent her longtime friend some love
during a dj set in las vegas
she also tweeted her support for brit
writing quote
11-11 make-a-wish
free britney
you